me da mucho gusto estar con ustedes el
día de hoy y la plática que voy a poder
compartir con ustedes es una parte de
una experiencia que tuve en un
campamento cuando tuve
17 años me di cuenta de todo lo que la
naturaleza podía ofrecer para nosotros y
fue una una aventura muy emocionante que
es lo que aprendí en toda esta en toda
esta aventura todo esto fue en eeuu y
había una chica llamada laurent singer
que tenía un blog que se llamaba trans y
expertos ers entonces lo que hacía esta
chica era demostrar como cabía toda su
basura en un frasco de vidrio y yo no lo
podía creer no podía pensar en que
pudiera existir esa posibilidad y
entonces decidí ponerme la misión de
hacerlo yo misma
entonces me di cuenta que
yo iba al súper normalmente como
cualquier persona normal y yo quería
saber cómo poder hacer mis compras sin
generar absolutamente nada de basura
cotidianamente comía un sandwich y comía
cosas muy fáciles de hacer porque por
supuesto que no sabía
cocinar absolutamente nada y entonces me
di cuenta de la cantidad gigantesca de
basura que producía por ejemplo un
sandwich ustedes pónganse a pensar todos
los residuos que se generan con un
sándwich empezando por el pan del
sándwich viene en una bolsa de plástico
después del jamón viene empacado en otra
como empaque de plástico el queso
también la lechuga ya desinfectada en
una bolsa de plástico y entonces no me
había dado cuenta de la cantidad de
basura que estaba generando todas las
semanas al yo estar consumiendo como
todos estos todas todas estas cosas que
generaban muchos residuos entonces un
día dije ya se acabó quiero intentar
hacer algo completamente distinto quiero
saber cómo hacerme un sandwich y sin
hacer basura puede sonar como la cosa
más tonta más fácil pero ustedes
pónganse a pensar o sea dónde van a
poder conseguir ese pan
sin la envoltura tuve que buscar una
panadería donde hicieran este tipo de
ese tipo de productos no había busqué y
busqué y busqué y se me hacía como
carísimo y ya lo encontré me lo llevé mi
servilleta de mi servilleta de tela y ya
muy feliz con el pan después empecé a
tener como cambios con el jamón con el
queso llevándome mi topper y para mí era
como wow estoy desbloqueando niveles de
de basura hasta que al final pude tener
mi mi sándwich ya sin generar ningún
tipo de residuo y entonces fue algo muy
interesante ponerme a pensar en todo eso
porque según yo ya era super ecológica
ya no pedía los potes ya no pedían las
bolsas ya llevaba mito para todos lados
y entonces empecé a descubrir que si
quería empezar a hacer las compras de
todas las semanas
todos los días tenía que ir a otro lugar
donde no era el supermercado porque en
el super todo bien empacado y dije bueno
pues voy a tener que ir a como
mercaditos empecé esta nueva aventura
comprando en los mercaditos y tenemos
que entender que no estamos descubriendo
el hilo negro si tú no sabes cómo hacer
algo sin generar basura pues pregúntale
a tu abuela cómo le hacía y
probablemente tiene la mejor solución y
la mejor alternativa entonces comencé a
dejar de ir tanto al súper y empecé a ir
más al tianguis y empecé a ir más al
supermercado y
me residuos y van bajando y bajando y
bajando y bajando cada vez más hasta que
un día me di cuenta que ya no tenía que
sacar la bolsa de basura porque si había
podido lograr todo un todas unas compras
de poder ir al súper sin hacer esta
basura ahora según yo ya así súper
ecofriendly increíble padrísimo todas
mis compras ya eran sin hacer basura
empecé a comprar muchos productos a
granel empecé a llevarme mixto pérez a
todos lados a cargar con mi servilleta
todo increíble y entonces para mí fue
como como si estuviera en un juego
interminable de ella tengo esta parte
resuelta y entonces un día me metí a
bañar y volteo y veo la botella de
champú la botella de acondicionador el
jabón
líquido con microesferas exfoliantes
jabón íntimo como que así un montón de
cosas llenas de empaques y yo no puede
ser ya había resuelto toda esta parte de
las compras sin hacer basura y ahora
tengo que enfrentarme a este nuevo nivel
que era los residuos en el baño poco a
poco empecé a cambiar por alternativas
sólidas como el champú sólido el
acondicionador sólido pues obviamente ya
no utilizaba este jabón líquido con
microesferas que al final esos son como
micro plásticos y empecé a utilizar
jabones artesanales sin empaque y fui
como desbloqueando estos niveles de
contaminación que según yo estaba estaba
generando hasta que llegó un momento en
el baño que volteo ya estaba todo sólido
vino de visita mi cuñada y mi hijo
o sea como que con qué me baño cuál es
el shampoo cuál es el acondicionador
todas eran barritas y dije igual si me
muero hoy ya este espacio de este
espacio del baño se va a desintegrar y
no voy a dejar huella en ese pequeño
espacio de mi casa entonces
llegué con con ese cambio y dije
perfecto nivel desbloqueado una vez más
me sentía la persona más ecofriendly del
mundo o sea ya había logrado hacer mi
súper sin basura ya había logrado tener
el baño lleno de cosas sólidas sin
empaque y después empecé a platicar con
muchas amigas y descubrimos que el tema
de la alimentación también era un tema y
yo no es que os haya no podemos hacer
nada todo contamina así de todas maneras
me voy a morir y todo contamina era un
estrés de pues entonces ya no como nada
ya no hago nada y empieza a un nuevo
nivel o sea yo había llevado a nivel 1
nivel 2 nivel 3 para mí fue todo el tema
de la alimentación porque una vez que ya
hacía todas mis compras sin generar
basura ya no tenía bolsa de basura pero
quedaban todos los residuos orgánicos y
dije no puede ser no quiero una composta
me da asco la odio los mosquitos me van
a correr de mi casa van a decir que
llegan bichos entonces era una cuestión
que me ponía muy nerviosa tuve que
buscar mucha información en internet
no había absolutamente nada todo era muy
confuso y dije no esto no no no no no no
no descubrí el proyecto de see top ya
donde me enseñaron a tener una
lombricomposta me daba todo el asco del
mundo agarrar lombrices y bichos y cosas
y dije no no puede ser pero bueno este
es el nivel número 3 al que voy a llegar
con este con esta locura de ecología
cuando llego a la parte de la composta
empiezo a darme cuenta que no todo podía
entrar en la composta o sea no podía
poner carne no podía poner huesos no
podía poner salchichas queso y entonces
empecé a cuestionarme el impacto que
pueden llegar a tener todos nuestros
alimentos cuánta agua se necesita para
que un cultivo de soya crezca un cultivo
de trigo y luego que las vacas lleguen y
se lo coman es todo un tema que te va
mal viajando y dices no entonces que me
como o sea una lechuga que yo coseche o
cuál va a ser la solución
entonces empecé a comer un poco más de
plantas y menos cosas de origen animal
que también si estás en este tipo de
procesos las personas deben entender que
no es forzoso tener que ponerte alguna
etiqueta con la cual no te sientas
cómodo y que el proceso de cada persona
es completamente diferente personal iba
a ser como con el tiempo y con las
herramientas que tenga cada persona
entonces empezó todo esto de querer
comer más plantas porque efectivamente
era de lo único que sí me sobraba iba a
poder echar en la composta entonces
empecé a comer más plantas empecé a
desperdiciar menos comida porque no
quería que me corriera de mi casa en ese
entonces con mis lombrices y con todos
mis bichos y dije órale ok estoy
aprendiendo que ahora no tengo que
desperdiciar ni siquiera la comida y me
costaba mucho trabajo desperdiciaba todo
el tiempo las calabacitas los jitomates
y yo decía es que porque está
desperdiciando todo tanto mi argumento
era porque no me da tiempo de cocinar
porque estoy súper ocupada soy
estudiante tengo que irme a la escuela
ya trabajar y entonces me di cuenta que
la razón por la cual no tenía tiempo era
porque pasaba mucho tiempo pero en el
celular todo el tiempo estaba en
instagram todo el tiempo estaba en
facebook todo el tiempo estaba viendo
netflix por supuesto que no me iba a dar
tiempo de hacer todo lo que yo quería
hacer cocinar me todas mis
miles de comidas del día y tampoco me
daba tiempo de ir a todas estas tiendas
entonces una gran parte de lo que he
descubierto en este viaje de tratar de
hacer más basura digo menos basura es a
no desperdiciar nada incluyendo el
tiempo el tiempo es algo que no puedes
desperdiciar nunca vas a poder
recuperarlo reciclarlo no vas a poder
decir absolutamente nada con el tiempo
que estás tirando a la basura y una vez
que entiendes todo esto puedes
prepararte para poder hacer tus compras
para poder cocinar todo lo que tú
necesites para poder ir a las tiendas
que necesites y vas a empezar a darte
cuenta que el tiempo que estás dándole a
tus gustos es lo a lo mejor ya a nivel 4
puse un huerto fue algo muy muy lindo y
muy interesante pero quiero que
entiendan que estamos en un juego
interminable y que tenemos que
divertirnos porque en este juego de la
vida solo tenemos una vida y tenemos que
aprovechar
muchísimas gracias